يترنحون بين الاسيجه كاشباه بلد يتفكك
ببطء يفرون خوفا على حياتهم حفاظا على ما
تبقى منها فهم يهربون من الحرب الى طي
النسيان كباقي اللاجئين في الاردن الالاف
يدخلون الاردن في حين يحمل كبار السن
الاطفال هذا الرجل يملاه الرعب بما يكفي
لجعله يمشي رغم اصابته في صدره ورغم ان
الجيش الاردني يريدنا ان نرى انهم يفعلون
ما في وسعهم الا انهم مغمورون بسيل من
اللاجئين اذ يعبر اكثر من 50 الف لاجئ في
الشهر الواحد هذا الطفل يبلغ من العمر سته
اشهر وتحتضنه والدته حمايه
له اما هذا الرجل فلا يمكنه التحدث بوضوح
ولا يستطيع حتى رفع قدميه بسبب
الاصابه الظلام يغطي السماء السوريه ودوي
القصف يسمع
قريبا وفي الجانب الاخر من الحدود هناك ما
يقارب 400 الف مشرد سوري وبعضهم بحاجه ماس
لتوقف
القصف ويظهر احد الثوار وهو يساعد سيده
على
الهروب لقد مروا برحله خطيره اثناء هروبهم
ليلا ونستطيع سماع دوي القصف قريبا هنا
بينما تنتظر هؤلاء اللاجئين محنه اخرى
الان ورغم ان الوضع امن هنا الا انها ليست
الحياه التي يريدونها والخوف المسيطر
عليهم يمنعهم من الظهور امام
الكاميرا ومع قدوم الدفء يبدا نقل
اللاجئين في الحافلات الى المخيمات
وترحيب الاردن لهم استنفدت اعدادهم
الهائله الا انها على كثرتها لا تزال في
البدايه فقط هؤلاء الثوار الثلاثه ليسوا
غير اطفال الا انهم تركوا عائلاتهم عوده
للقتال بعزيمه الرجال شباب ولكن عائلات
نسبه نزوح كبيره جدا من جميع محافظه درعا
جميع انحاء درعا يعني ما فيش منطقه يعني
عدد السكان بنعد بالكم شخص بالكم عيله فقط
يعني
سوريه مهجره تفوتي على البلد مثلا 20 25
بينما تتقلص المساحه التي تحتويهم
هنا